this is more brutally honest advice to
my younger poor self this advice is only
for somebody who wants to make more
money grow in their business grow in
themselves people obsessed with their
morning routines make less money than
people obsessed with making money people
work sacrifice and then they get rich
then they fill their time with weird
routines then they forget how they got
rich in the first place and then they
tell other people the weird routines
made them Rich rather than what they
actually did which is whatever it took
not some 3-hour morning routine there
was a kid who dm' me who said hey I've
been working with this business coach
and he has me doing a morning routine
could not make this up after I do my
grounded walking I do my gratitude
Journal I do my list for the day I do my
ice plunge it's like after I do that he
takes me about 3 hours in the morning to
get all that done he's like I barely
have any energy to like actually get
work done I just said I'm going to give
you the biggest hack in the world cut
the 3-hour morning routine replace it
with 3 hours of work and I promise
you'll get more done and he messaged me
back a week later he was like dude it
changed my whole life I'm getting so
much done now I was like what a [__]
concept if you work more more gets done
and I love just looking at this it's
like what actions do I have to take to
get what I want anything that is not
that is a distraction from it period if
it takes you 5 minutes to feel 20%
better and you can actually measure that
your output goes up by 20% Then cool
that makes sense so I'm not I'm not
against doing things I'm against doing
things for the sake of doing
them and so one of the biggest issues
with learning and education as humans do
it is that we make correlations to
things that are approximate they're
close to another tall people play
basketball I should play basketball to
get tall we make these very mistaken
correlations but we should look at is
what it took to get there not what
they're doing now so the better advice
is to look at what someone was doing on
their way up in the grind mirror that
more than what they're currently doing
at the top of the mountain so it would
be like assuming warm Buffett is Rich
because he drinks Coke I drink probably
5 12 ounce Cokes a day all you have to
do also on the cories are there other
people who drink Coke who aren't Rich
I've had probably 10 different podcasts
seed the premise do you think that the
fact that you had a hard childhood has
created the success today and I would
say no I would say the work that I did
created the success and all we have to
do is look at all the other people who
had bad childhoods who aren't successful
and I think there are way more of those
than there are that are to prove that it
actually has nothing to do with who's
successful there's also people who
didn't have bad childhoods who are
successful too and so it's just that
many people have bad childhoods some of
them become successful and so that's why
trying to figure out why something
happen happened I have spent less and
less of my effort trying to do that and
only look at what actions created a
result rather than looking at intention
or anything else that's a morphous that
can't be
measured 30 isn't the new 20 it's an
excuse to take 10 years longer to
accomplish the same thing you can die
when you're done until then keep going
in your 20s you're young you can [__]
around it doesn't matter cuz life is
long number one that assumes that you're
not going to die if you're in your 30s
you know someone someone in your high
school class who died and it's not just
the drug overdose people it's the people
who got shot got in a car accident had a
weird brain cancer I've had all of those
things happened to people that I went to
high school with in one way I think it's
a little bit arrogant to assume that
you're just going to live because it
means you can waste your life and I I
wholeheartedly stand against that the
second translation around that that I
think has hurt a lot of people is that
they can do what I would consider
dead-end jobs and that means jobs that
don't have any direct correlation to
your personal growth has nothing to do
with pay you can work for free and grow
more than anyone else this is not saying
that you need to go into a season of
earning in your 20s but you do need to
be setting yourself up for growth in my
opinion if you want the big ultimate
outcome and so most people that at least
consume my stuff they want to be better
they want to grow they want to get in
better shape they want to have better
relationships they want to have a better
business they want to be you know bigger
in every way they want to expand if you
spend the decade of your 20s not growing
and not investing in your skills and
your education if if you do that in your
30s you're going to be further behind
than someone who starts in their 20s
you're going to be a decade behind you
know nowadays there's kids who are
starting the entrepreneurial Journey
when they're like 13 and so when they're
23 they're Mr Beast he's young but he's
actually pretty old in business terms CU
a lot of people start their business
journey in their mid-40s and so if
they're 50 years old and started their
business 5 years ago Mr Beast has twice
the amount of time in the ring under the
bar that they do for me I want to start
my time clock on paying down my
ignorance debt as fast as seemingly
possible because the debt is a constant
for everyone all of us are trying to pay
down that debt as fast as we can and
taking a decade arguably one of the most
productive Decades of your life and not
paying down that debt you just sit in
such a deficit compared to your peer
group some people might watch this and
be 30 or 40 or 50 and be like well [__]
I took the wrong advice from the wrong
guy guess what you're going to die it's
not going to matter anyways big deal
whatever the best time to do this was
start when you were 10 and get born to
an entrepreneurial parent who got you in
their small business and invested in all
of your education as a homeschooled
student and taught you all the ways of
of the of the
Jedi but you probably didn't have that
and so the second was time is to start
now because let's play out the
alternative how much does it serve you
to just say I guess I have no chance
okay die there's nothing left for me to
do I will relinquish the remainder of my
living days and years because I choose
to lose and that's a choice and if you
want that that's cool the idea of
quitting simply because you're older
because you didn't do something
everybody doesn't do things that they
know they should be doing now and that's
because you're always going to know more
in the future than you do in the past
and so it's a faulty premise to say that
I'm not going to take action today
because I didn't know something in the
past everyone doesn't know anything in
the past but all you can do is take
action with what you know today and by
taking action you have learned and so
you actually take one step to making
your first payment on ignorance debt
through actions not words I mean I think
a lot of people know the story of the
30-year-old Barista if you love that
then do it you know what I mean like I
have no judgment on what you do do if
you don't love that and you wish you
were doing something else that's what I
would say I have a problem with which is
why are you not doing it and I think
diving into that which is usually some
sort of fear some sort of anxiety some
sort of label that they believed that
isn't true from someone else and just
trying to Zone in on like why am I not
doing it and taking two steps closer to
it not just like because I don't know
what I'm doing well duh okay neither
does anyone what are you doing about
that just defining it to what actions am
I going to take as a result just makes
life a lot easier what does figured out
mean it means that I'm going to read 2
hours a night on a specific subject
until I feel like I can make a decision
within 30 days on what I'm going to do
great that is something I can do and I
can measure whether I did it or
not you have seasons of earning and you
have seasons of learning I had this kid
who reached out he was 18 years old said
he was going to edit videos for us when
he came in he said I want $100,000 a
year as an editor as a starting job his
reasoning was that somebody else had
offered him that amount of money I want
to make this statement because I think
it's logic iCal and also stupid if
you're optimizing for your earning
potential in your 20s you're missing the
[__] point this individual had the
potential to be on a team that has a
massively globally recognized brand in
terms of media and from there learn how
to be way better than they currently are
and then become a creative director at
another company or at one of my
portfolio companies like that is the
career path and instead was comparing
that to something that you would make
$100,000 a year and be the only person
in the depart department and no one
there knew anything about media and so
he wasn't going to learn he was going to
earn whereas somebody who got into the
big leagues and learned 10 times the
skill set then 10 years later is either
starting a multi-million dollar company
or heading up a multi-million dollar
division in a billion dollar company and
the potential is so much wider because
10 years from now someone says what's
your experience it's like well I I
worked at a real estate firm and I made
their social media content who gives a
[__] whereas if you're like I work for
one of the biggest media companies out
there everyone will give you the job
offer and that is when you can choose to
earn over learn but people make the
trade too soon because they compare
themselves to people on social media and
think that the
.1% is the norm whenever you choose to
earn rather than learn you're right
hooking life and saying I'm no longer
going to develop and this is good enough
and so if $100,000 a year is actually
good enough for your long-term goals
then do it but I would imagine that it
probably isn't for what you really want
to do long term and I'm using 100 you
know six figures as a as a placeholder
it can be whatever number you want when
you make that decision that you're no
longer going to learn that's when you
stop growing your potential to learn
more I say this because that's what I
did I had a white Coller consulting job
for defense Contracting I had a top
secret clearance I had everything that
looked good on paper space I
intelligence I had a two to threee path
clearly for for getting an MBA at an IV
League school and then decided to drop
all of that and start working for $13 an
hour at a gym after I graduated magn
klady in 3 years from banderol I know
what I'm asking people to do and I'm not
asking them to do something that I
wasn't willing to do and I think that I
might have even a more extreme version
that most people are having to live with
trying to say like well I can't figure
out what I want is a really paralyzing
place to be that I think a lot of young
people are in is like I want to find my
passion but the big misnomer is actually
a language issue which is that people
say they want to find their passion
rather than they want to build it or
create it or learn it and so like I can
promise you that if you're good at
something you'll like doing it and the
only way that you get good at something
is by doing things you suck at and doing
a lot of
it so let's say you make $50,000 a year
it cost you $950,000 a year not to know
how to make a million do a year so how
much is that education worth answer the
difference the difference between $1
million and $50,000 which is $950 Grand
if you learn how to make a million the
education is worth the difference this
is why education and information are the
most valuable things that we can know
Elon has like lost everything and then
gain it back so many of the best off
Runners have stories where they lost it
all and then gain it back and so how is
it that they can go to to zero back to a
billion where somebody starting at zero
can't get there because they didn't lose
the education they didn't lose the
learnings they had a bad role and
sometimes in business you do make bets
on markets and sometimes they don't
shape up but you didn't lose and a lot
of times you actually gain in experience
so that the next bet pays off even
bigger everyone gets this wrong the most
expensive thing you ever pay for isn't
your car it isn't your house it isn't
your insurance it's the information that
you don't know but should I mean how
many things can you think of right now
that if you knew 10 years ago would have
materially changed your financial
outcome your relational outcome your
physical outcomes probably a lot what is
the value of that information borderline
Priceless and so the idea that we
wouldn't invest in paying down that debt
of ignorance that we owe the universe is
just because we don't know who we're
paying the check to every month for the
things that we don't know that we don't
value it appropriately the cost of
success is the years of feeling like an
idiot for things that you should have
known by now all the the decisions that
I made up to to this point led me to
hear and I don't regret my life so I
don't regret not knowing I mean if I
started over I'd be wealthier than I am
now you know what I
mean I can't go back in time but if I
could go back in time to talk to my
20-year-old self and it wouldn't change
the outcome of my life now cuz I would
never roll that dice is I would say
there's two things that you don't
understand that will massively change
your life you don't understand brand and
you don't understand product because I
was obsessive in my 20s on sales and
marketing and what I would consider fast
money I had fast feedback loops so I
would I get better at sales and then I
immediately make more sales I get better
marketing immediately make more money
and so I had this very fast feedback
loop that gave me the misinformation or
the false belief that this was the right
path but I was actually just playing the
wrong game because it's kind of like in
The Matrix when Neo says to morphus so
you're saying when I'm fast enough I'll
be able to dodge bullets and he said no
I'm saying when you're ready you won't
have to me being obsessive about sales
and marketing was me trying to get
faster and faster in the Matrix and not
being the one and seeing the code for
what it is which is that if you make a
product that's good enough people will
do the marketing and sales for you if
your brand is strong enough people will
make the association that they want to
buy your stuff regardless of how good
your copy and your headline and your
landing pages and your conversion rate
optimization and your media buying are I
kept getting really good at a game that
if I knew how to master the big things
that mattered would make those skills
almost irrelevant when $100 million
offers came out the book I didn't make
it for anything I made it for me and it
was originally intended to be an
internal document and so I just wanted
to make it exceptional and what happened
once I released it is what shocked me
the most was that I posted once and I
just said hey I wrote this book I hope
you guys like it and then we sold out in
minutes and I was like that's weird the
next month more copies sold and then the
next month more copies sold and it's
continued to sell more copies month
after month after month for 2 years and
it's still number one in its category on
Amazon and that was with zero paid
marketing purely off of people telling
people about the book and so when I saw
how much leverage that was that that
book sells thousands a day not dollars
thousands of copies a day I have never
marketed anything well enough to sell a
thousand customers a day now mind you
I've always had more expensive stuff
that I've sold but like I'd never seen
that kind of transaction volume and the
only way to get that kind of transaction
volume is to have a huge amount of
Leverage The Leverage that product
unlocked for me or that understanding
was that if you make it good enough and
I love this saying which is there's too
big to fail and I love the other which
is too good to
fail my headline for $100 million off
offers makes no sense no one knows what
$100 million offers is and it's just
like a picture of a $100 bill it's a big
purple book like it actually makes no
sense but the contents of the book were
valuable enough that people were like
just just read it and they said it so
many times to so many people and most
people who when I see the comments and I
see the reviews they say I had four
different people in the same month tell
me in different groups that I should
read this book so I decided to do it
even though it looked hokey and oh my
God this thing is unbelievable and then
they tell 20 people or 100 people that
was when I realized how much Leverage
spending more time upfront on building a
better product would unlock for me what
I used to do was spend 2 months building
a good product and spend two years
marketing that product with great
marketing rather than spending two years
on a great product and then for the rest
of my life not having to spent any
dollars or effort on marketing so that
it would sell again and again and again
because of the quality of the product
itself and so that was the first lesson
that my younger self needed to
understand about business and the level
of detail that it takes to go from good
to Great is so much wider than people
think it is the difference between an
eight and a nine is 10 times the wor the
difference between 9 and 9 and a half is
10 times the work the difference between
9 and a half and 9.75 is another 10
times the work it's so much more effort
and honestly when I was younger I
couldn't even comprehend the amount of
work that I can do now and for me that
amount of work is the amount of unbroken
Focus time that I can stick with one
task I did not have that level of focus
I didn't have a strong enough no muscle
I didn't know how to turn down other
things that would distract me for long
enough if you can count in terms of
hundreds like I can promise you if you
put a th000 hours into something it'll
probably be pretty good and most people
spend like a 100 hours on something or I
mean that's [__] most people spend even
less than time than that you start a
clock when you start working you stop a
clock when you stop working you spend
1,000 hours or 2,000 hours on something
there's a level of detail because of the
number of exposures you'll get to it the
crispy details of the product or the
service that can only come from looking
at that thing when it's cold looking at
thing when it's hot looking at it when
you're angry looking at it when you're
sad looking at it when you're inspired
looking at it when you're bored you see
it with different lenses and then what
happens is it just gives you so much
more depth and context to whatever
you're trying to build that that's the
difference between mediocre products and
excellent products and it just takes
time in an ocean of volume which there's
more commoditized products and services
today than ever before there is outsized
returns to being number one it is an
even bigger win or take all market now
than it ever has been because of social
media and the ease of letting other
people know about stuff if you are truly
the best everyone will know and if
everyone knows you are the best you will
have more demand than you can possibly
deal with people think the word of mouth
is dead when there's literally never
been an easier way to go viral in a
literal sense from people telling other
people about
stuff I said the second lesson was brand
and so I had to look at a company or
brand as a learning tool as what are
people going to learn to associate my
brand with the tangible and the
intangible ideas there are many people
that I associated with when I was
younger that I would never associate
with today even though I would say well
I don't act that way I don't live my
life the way they live their lives
people would still make that Association
if I did nothing but talk with porn
stars on my show people would still make
a very different association with me and
so I want to embody certain values that
I want my brand to associate with and
anything that is not those things by
default detracts from it because it
dilutes the association branding is like
curating a garden where pretty much
anything but the flower that you're
trying to grow there is a weed
even if it's a daffodil even if it's a
sunflower even if the flower itself is
fine like I said I have no issues with
porn I think it's a sunflower whatever
but if I'm trying to grow roses that
anything that's not a rose doesn't
belong being so Vigilant about defending
that Garden of Association and
reputation gives you so much leverage
because the reason Warren Buffett now
can just do deals that no one else can
do is because his handshake means more
than the US governments if he says he
will pay we know he will pay if he says
he will be there to ensure your entire
city we know he will he can do a deal on
a one-page agreement for billions of
dollars because people trust and they
know that his reputation matters more
than anything to him and so trust is
leverage for deals it's leverage for
sales the first experience I had with
having a strong brand was when we were
probably a year year and a half into gym
launch I launched what would become
Allen my software project and when
people heard I had launched a new thing
the clients that I had were sending
screenshots of their credit cards to my
C customer support team saying I don't
know what it was but if Alex made it
I'll buy it and so all of the ideas and
the obsessions around how it was going
to Market it and how I was going to
position it the thing that mattered most
was what they had already received from
me and how much I had delivered on my
first promise and so when I realized
that I was like all of this sales and
marketing stuff gets you one sale
delivering exceptional product an
exceptional reputation around your
products gets you every other sale after
that and you will always be able to sell
the next thing provided you delivered on
the first thing and that's where there's
this obsession with marketing because
there's always more people to sell to
it's a very in my opinion tiring life
you always have to go get new customers
if you make sales to get customers
rather than get customers to make sales
you make the customer the goal and then
you get to keep that relationship and
then next year you still have that
customer if you got a customer just to
make a sale you have to go get another
customer to make another sale next year
but if you make a sale to create the
relationship of the customer then next
year that customer will buy again and
the new customer will buy bu and the
third year you get the first two years
and the Third customer and then that is
how you create a compounding vehicle and
so both of those things brand and
product are actually underlying one
concept now that I'm saying it out loud
which is I didn't understand compounding
I thought that it was normal to have to
go out bang doors call phones DM run ads
to get customers every single month and
that next month I'm going to have to get
another 20 just to keep the lights on
rather than having spent more time on my
reputation and the quality of my product
so that when I sold the first they would
never leave again and then they would
send me the next 100 and I wouldn't have
to do anything and then I would be able
to fend people off and then I'd be able
to raise my prices and be able to take
people on my terms but I didn't
understand any of that and part of that
is because I wanted money so fast and
building a great product takes longer
building a great reputation literally
never stops until the day you die
leaning into that lesson you know the
first book I launched and I think it did
two or 4,000 copies sold its first month
something like that you know the second
book that launched 2 years later sold
250,000 copies cop in its first month
which for context the average New York
Times best sell ourselves between 10 and
100,000 in its first 12 months and we
sold 250 in the first month the only way
that that can happen is if the people
who bought the first book buy the second
book and everybody they tell also buys
and that book still continues to sell at
twice the rate of my first book
today here's how to spot friends that
are worth cutting they only talk about
your past not your future so if you go
and you hang out with your buddies and
all they can really reminisce with you
on is the things that you did together
but none of them are talking about what
they're going to do or what you're going
to do for me that's a Telltale sign that
they're living in the past they're not
even living in the present their best
years are behind them and for most of us
we want our best years to be ahead of us
and we want somebody who's also looking
at the same goal as us which is growth
which is moving forward just making
progress if you are a growth oriented
individual and you feel like you're not
sure about your environment or if it's
conducive the easiest liment test is who
talks about the future and who talks
about the past keep the ones who only
talk about the future future cut the
ones talking about the past the best
thing that I ever did was not listen to
other people's opinions about my life
they don't want the best version of you
they want the version of you who best
serves them now when I first said this I
got Flack from a bunch of parents they
were like I really want the best for my
kids I was like that's not true you want
a version of your children who serves
what you think will make you look the
best family I would say more often than
not has a closer alignment with your
long-term goals than strangers do and so
it makes sense that family would have
more aligned interests but not
completely aligned interests with you
cuz the only person who has a completely
aligned interest with you is future you
keeping that as the litmus test of whose
opinion I'm going to listen to although
it's more difficult has ultimately been
very fruitful for me because if you're
looking at two even two parents you can
disprove that concept by saying okay
well both parents want different things
for me of the things that both parents
want which of the things help each of
the parents individually out cu I can
promise you that the thing that one
parent wants doesn't hurt them and help
the other parent if they disagree it's
usually something that's more aligned
with their worldview their beliefs or
what they will get status from in their
Community for you doing and so all of
the things I just described have nothing
to do with you so why consider it I'll
say this upfront I hate why questions
cuz who knows why but I would say that I
if if I had to make a guess on why we
care about other people's opinions it's
because we've learned to care about
other people's opinions and when we're
children we learn to orient ourselves to
the world through other people telling
us what is what literally when you're a
kid you point and then you say what's
that and then they say this and so you
have to listen to other people on the
way up the problem is at some point you
have to turn it off and say you know
some of the people I was listening to
had no idea what they were saying but
you don't know they have no idea because
you don't have a context to make a
judgment you have to learn to become
human and then you have to learn to
become yourself and I think that at that
Turning Point you then have to analyze
the beliefs that you've been given and
then keep the ones that you choose most
parents are risk averse rather than
risk-taking for for their children so
like we are willing to take more risk
for ourselves often times than our
parents are willing to take on our
behalf and I think that's normal they
want to like keep you alive there's a
lot of evolutionary Drive behind that
and so they're playing not to lose but
if you want to play to win then you have
to take different bets I think a lot of
younger people get really confused
because they spend a lot of time talking
about ideas and very little talking
about doing actions and so if you just
Define the World by only things that
occur in it and not things that occur in
your mind there's a lot less noise and
so it becomes easier to see the farest
from the trees let's say I have an
employee and I want I hop on a
one-on-one and they said something in a
meeting before and I say I think the
intention behind your statement was that
you wanted me to do this and this is how
I was feeling about your statement and
this is probably where you were feeling
everything I just said is a complete
waste of time because all I know is that
they said this and so just focus on the
facts and if you can do that it actually
makes living life a lot easier or
navigating life a lot easier at least it
has for me because those are the only
objective truths an easy frame for that
is like would it be admitted to a court
at as evidence you saying you were
offended is not evidence John said this
to Sally these words that's evidence
indisputable and so just look at the
things that are Beyond reproach look at
the things that are indisputable look at
the things that are facts that are
observable and the world gets a lot
quieter and you also realize that most
people are full of [__] and don't know
what they're talking about I mean if
someone was like hey Alex why did you
get into business I could make up an
answer it just how do we know it's true
trying to figure out someone's intention
is [__] if someone ask me why did
you get into business I can make up an
answer anyone can make up an answer why
do you like making money why do you like
sales why do you like marketing why are
you good at this I can make up any
answer all I know is that these things
have occurred and so we can look at my
actions and we can look at the results
the rest of it of which which had what
influence on what like I can't relive my
life and I can't run the experiment and
so trying to determine why like was it
because my mom didn't hug me was it
because my dad hugged me too hard who
knows I can give anyone and someone will
nod and say great because we've trained
ourselves to say to answer when someone
says why do you do that you give them
words and they nod and say oh that's
interesting but like it doesn't does
mean it's true and so I just try and
skirt the whole conversation because
there's no point so when someone's like
well I'm the type of person who I'm like
just stop then they start using this
label to decide whether or why they can
or can't do something I wouldn't be
successful with that cuz I'm a KN freak
why because you take trash out of your
car regularly why does that have
anything to do with whether you could do
this or not I used to think and told
people I was bad at math until I was 25
post College post consulting job all of
it and then I decided that I was not
going to be bad at math and so I was
like okay well I'm not going to use a
calculator and so then I started getting
better and better at doing math problem
and then lo and behold uh when I took
the GMAT I was like okay I have to study
twice as hard for the math section and I
did just as well on the math section as
I did on my verbal but my whole life I
had said I was bad at math and so I
didn't study as hard because I was bad
at it everyone who's listening to this
has something they say about themselves
they're like I'm not organized I'm an
early bird right like we have these
labels we give ourselves but like why do
we have these labels like if you needed
to wake up early [__] wake up early
if you need to stay up late you stay up
late the labels change our Behavior more
than we change the labels I really abhor
labels overall because I feel like it
limits my action when I get on podcasts
and I have talks and people try and
label me you'll probably actively see me
break the label almost every time
because I'm really aware of it and a lot
of people aren't and I don't think
people do it on purpose in a bad way I
just think that they will speak things
over you which is why I hate going home
because no one speaks [__] over you more
than your family and the people who knew
you in high school Alex has always had a
short temper you you're a hotthead
literally people from home describe me
that way I was like I don't think I'm a
hotthead they will say that and then I
feel like I have to really put up my
mental like defenses to be like this is
not true here is the evidence that this
is not true what would a hothead do in
these scenarios that is not the way I
behaved therefore right and i' have to I
have to basically unwind that [__]
whenever I go there and so that is why
I've been an advocate of like if you
want to change your behavior change your
environment because they're not going to
reinforce labels that you then also
perpetuate in your own mind by the
actions you take as a result and the
only reason they want to label is
because it's shorthand for other people
to understand not cuz it's true they
just want to say he had a bad shot and
so they take your whole life and they
just say bad that's not true there's
more Nuance to it I prefer to think of
ideals and think of taking steps towards
those ideals and since ideals are not
binary of like he is courageous or he is
not courageous but how courageous is he
or how patient is he not impatient or
patient but how much then I know the
values that I want to embody and then I
just take steps towards those every day
with the actions I take and so if I'm
deciding do I want to take this action I
say which action aligns most with the
values that would have EMB body and then
I try to do that so rather than being
like Alex is patient i' be like Alex
attempts to act in accordance with the
value of patience and sometimes fall
short but dries his Darkness